[Music]  this is a safe place  i'm agoraphobic i can't  go inside i've been sleeping  getting into a really dark frame of mind  [Music]  so what's the latest on the street  she's become a friend her name is jane  russell  do you want to go outside you know i  have a shrimp  [Music]  foreign  [Music]  little nypd where's jane mr wrestle  believes that you made a mistake you  have never met my wife  ma'am you all right i know jane jane's  been in my house  i'm jane russell not crazy  i know what i saw they're all hiding  something  you will not never have my mother  stop watching our your house  said that your meds can cause  hallucinations  i'm not hallucinating  i think there is somebody in my house  don't go looking into other people's  [Music]  houses  [Music]  [Music]  you